mein Thema des Tages greifen ist weg
soll das Robert Habeck entschieden und
heute auch verkündet hören wir doch
bitte einmal rein
entsprechend der Vorlage hat am 30.11 22
Patrick reichen eine Liste mit drei
Projektskizzen gebilligt eines dieser
Projekte stammt vom Bund Landesverband
Berlin mit einer Fördersumme von knapp
600.000 Euro
allerdings ist im Landesverband Berlin
die Schwester von Patrick reichen
Vorstandsmitglied
in der Gesamtschau hat sich Patrick
reichen damit zu angreifbar gemacht um
sein Amt noch wirkungsvoll ausüben zu
können
ich beabsichtige daher den
Bundespräsidenten zu bitten Patrick
reichen in den eins verdienen Ruhestand
zu versetzen
[Musik]
ja die Entlassung reichens ist
überfällig Harbeck hat jetzt die
Reißleine gezogen doch seine Erklärung
ist eher dürftig Herr Bosbach ist das
für habe jetzt die Flucht nach vorne ja
das ist die Flucht nach vorne weil er
gemerkt hat dass die Medien insbesondere
der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
langsam aber sicher den Schutzzaun
abbaut den man jahrelang um die Grünen
gezogen hat jetzt wird auf einmal selbst
bei den Grünen genau hingesehen obwohl
man ja immer so den Eindruck erweckt hat
das sind die besseren Politiker das ist
die moralisch höher stehende Partei bei
denen müssen wir uns keine Sorgen machen
und dann sieht man das ist wie bei
anderen auch und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass die Begründung die er
habe gerade gegeben hat dass das die
entscheidende Begründung für die
Entlassung von Herrn reichen ist da muss
es noch mehr gegeben haben ob und wann
das rauskommt ist eine andere Frage aber
es war überfällig da das ist noch mehr
an Vetternwirtschaft gegeben hat oder es
muss noch nicht immer böser Wille oder
Absicht sein an Ungeschicklichkeiten wo
man sagt das geht nicht ist ja nicht nur
erlaubt und verboten es gibt auch die
Kategorie das tut man nicht und das was
wir wir jetzt schon wissen ist too much
damit war er nicht mehr im Amt zu halten
ja würdest du zustimmen ich glaube
faktisch hat Robert Habeck heute
Bedingungen oder oder Entwicklungen
vorgetragen um diesen Rauswurf am Ende
des jahreswurf gewesen auch dann
begründen zu können aber mit dabei
Wolfgang Bosbach meint ist das natürlich
im Hintergrund noch viel mehr an Musik
bei den Grünen gelaufen ist die hatten
eine Landtagswahl in Bremen bei denen
die Grünen ein Drittel ihrer Stimmen
verloren haben zumindest Blick auf das
Ergebnis ist das dramatisch
ja auf die liegt in einigen bundesweiten
Umfang ja sowieso schon seit längerem
vor den Grünen und dann gibt es zwei
entscheidende und sehr wichtige für die
Grünen auch Landtagswahlen im Oktober
und nach allem was wir hören gab es auch
in den letzten Tagen sehr sehr viel
Besorgnis in diesem Landesverbänden in
Hessen und Bayern das Robert Habeck mit
seinem Sekretär Patrick reichen nicht
dazu beiträgt dass es eher ein gutes
Ergebnis wird sondern eher dass das
Ergebnis in die gegenteilige Richtung
läuft und das ist nachher in der
parteilicher Druck der natürlich bei
Robert Habeck ankommt aufläuft und bei
dem Robert habe ich irgendwann auch
sagen musste das kann ich so nicht
weitermachen schließlich will Robert
habe ich ja noch Bundeskanzler werden
aber was ja ganz spannend ist Robert
Habeck hat ja auch in der letzten Zeit
immer wieder gesagt aber er ist so
wichtig ergreifen ist so wichtig
ergreifen hat so viel geleistet was
macht der Arbeit denn jetzt ohne Herrn
reichen was seine energiepläne betrifft
das wird man sehen das ist sehr spannend
vor allem im Blick auf das sogenannte
heitzhammer gesetzt wie wir es nennen
das Gebäude Energiegesetz das hat
Haarwerk heute auch noch mal gesagt soll
ja bis zur Sommerpause verabschiedet
werden aber es ist ein entscheidender
Punkt reichen hat es anscheinstelle
ausgearbeitet aber es führt auch zu so
viel Frust und Unmut in der Bevölkerung
und zwar nicht weil es irgendwie
durchgestochen wurde wie auch immer
sondern weil das Gesetz einfach so
massive Belastungen für Millionen von
Bürgern mit sich bringt das ist deswegen
viel Kritik geht und das ist etwas was
die Grünen auch Robert habe bis heute
nicht richtig verknusen können dass man
plötzlich mal ihre Politik kritisiert ja
hinterfragt daraus wird immer gleich
eine Kampagne von rechts oder der Fossil
Lobby völliger Quatsch hier geht so
etwas ganz legitimes in der Demokratie
dass die Grünen über offenbar über Jahre
nicht gewöhnt waren dass man ihre
Positionen auch mal kritisiert
hinterfragt und da fehlt jetzt Patrick
reichen in der Tat und deswegen wird
spannend zu sehen sein wenn Robert
Habeck als seine rechte Hand bei diesem
Gesetz dann auf den Stuhl des
Staatssekretär befördert wird waren sie
auch froh dass Patrick reichen nun
zurückgetreten beziehungsweise im
Vorruhestand entlassen wurde er kriegt
er jetzt auch Rente dazu kommen wir
nachher noch mal nee weil ich
tatsächlich nicht ich war auch sehr
erstaunt dass habe ich nachdem er den
Rücken gestärkt hat noch vor einigen
Tagen dass Sie dass er ihn jetzt
tatsächlich entlässt und ich würde sagen
das Problem oder der Grund warum Patrick
reichen jetzt zurücktreten musste war ja
weil die Union also die Opposition hat
extrem viel Druck aufgebaut sie haben
das mit einer einer Sprache gemacht die
ich nicht gut heiße sie haben von dem
reichen Clan geredet sie haben von dem
Paten geredet also ihn in die Nähe der
Mafia gerückt von einer kriminellen
Vereinigung 600.000 Euro ist ja eine der
Summen an die Schwester ja also ich will
das persönliche Fehlverhalten von
Herrchen nicht gutheißen das war auf
jeden Fall ein Fehler aber ich denke in
einer Demokratie können wir auch mal
Fehler zugestehen und Herren hat ja
diesen Fehler anerkannt er hat sich
entschuldigt dafür und die bei dieser
Trauzeugen Affäre wurde ja der Posten
wieder neu ausgeschrieben also er dieser
Fehler wurde auch korrigiert und ich
würde sagen dabei hätte man es belassen
können und mein Eindruck ist dass die
Union sich nach außen hin natürlich auf
dieses persönliche Fehlverhalten
konzentriert aber natürlich ist er hatte
ist das eine große politische Komponente
ergreifen hat die Energiewende in einer
Geschwindigkeit vorangetrieben und hat
die Fehler der Vergangenheit korrigiert
und ich glaube das ging einen in der
Union die er doch einige hat in eine
Branche die vielleicht dieser Politik
sehr kritisch gegenüber steht da wurde
jetzt eine ich nenne es eine Kampagne
tatsächlich gemacht das wurde aus einem
persönlichen Fehlverhalten ein
politischer Skandal aufgezogen und ja
Habeck wird ja es ist ein ein schlechter
Tag für Deutschland das Patrick reichen
gehen musste fachlich ist er enorm
qualifiziert es gibt wahrscheinlich
niemanden der besser für diesen Job
geeignet
ich bin kein kommen sie eigentlich auf
die Idee das Kritik automatisch eine
Kampagne ist also muss ich dann das
verstehen was die taz über andreas
Scheuer geschrieben hat oder was die
Grünen über Andreas scheuert gesagt
haben ist das immer eine Kampagne dann
gewesen also ist grüne Kritik an
Politikern beispielsweise der Union
immer automatisch eine Kampagne nein es
geht darum wie es etwas aufgezogen ne
also wenn wir die CDU hat jetzt
tatsächlich eine Kampagne gestartet
gegen das heizungsgesetz ne unter dem
Slogan verheizen und hatte darum danke
bisher nicht gegen eine gewisse Partei
sondern das war eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Bewegung über
Jahrzehnte also das ist ja eine Bewegung
die aus der Gesellschaft kommt und eine
Kampagne in dem Fall ist von einer
Partei von einer Oppositionspartei
gegenüber der Regierungspartei der
Regierungskoalition angestrebt und ich
finde eine
Oppositionspartei sollte konstruktive
Vorschläge bringen wie wir etwas zu
ändern ist und nicht eine Kampagne
starten politischen Punkt
die Welt war das die Welt die Tatsache
ja also ich heiße ja nicht dieses
Verhalten der Kampagne nein nein nein es
geht ja nicht darum geht ja nicht darum
dass man das nicht kritisieren darf dass
Herr kreischen nicht wirklich zwischen
persönlichen und beruflichen trennen
konnte ne aber es geht darum dass man
auch mal ähm dass man etwas in seiner
Qualität richtig einschätzen muss das
war ein persönliches Fehlverhalten das
wurde korrigiert und dabei hätte man es
auch sein lassen weil Herrchen ist ein
sehr sehr wichtiger war ein sehr sehr
wichtiger Mann für die Energiewende aber
die die Union oder die Opposition
wittert dort natürlich die politischen
Punkte jetzt können Sie die Grünen
angreifen
was hätten sie ja nicht verziehen wenn
ich das fragen darf
das weiß ich jetzt nicht wo man da genau
die Grenze zieht aber Wort vielleicht
das wäre dann schon Grund gewesen
zurückzutreten also vielleicht gibt es
irgendwelche Mittelweg ich glaube
die Verlegenheit zu kommen
zur Seite stehen zu wollen oder zu
müssen
aber SPD ähm Koalition genauso aber
schon eine andere Partei war schon
insofern recht als dass der Ton die
Musik spielt Musik macht und von klaren
und so weiter zu sprechen Mafia
Strukturen das war doch ein bisschen zu
hart das ist für eine Demokratie auch
nicht wirklich förderlich es zu
kritisieren wiederum gehört aber
tatsächlich dazu ist die Aufgabe der
Opposition haben die Grünen regelmäßig
gemacht und ich glaube das ist
vielleicht auch der Punkt dass sie sonst
auch genauso scharf schießen oder
austeilt muss auch einstecken können ich
glaube aber dass der Punkt oder folgende
ist in dem Moment wo eine
Personaldebatte eine sachdebatte
überschattet und zwar nachhaltig und
eben länger als zwei Tage oder drei Tage
und die Aufgaben die vorher vom Minister
Habeck liegen sind ja große und wichtige
für das dazu dass man dann nicht mehr
die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen
kann und deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich
genau die richtige Entscheidung zu
diesem Punkt gekommen so dass wir
endlich wieder auf die Sache kommen
müssen ich mache der Union keine
Vorwürfe dass sie das hinterfragt und
kritisiert haben ich mache der Union
aber schon Vorwürfe für dass sie eine
Tonart an dieser Stelle man muss dann
gucken man muss dann Anstand eben auch
nicht irgendwie einer Garderobe immer
abgeben im politischen Schlag Abtausch
ich bin kein ähm ich bin auch kein
Weichei einfach sowas angeht aber man
muss schon aufpassen man hat irgendwie
auch eine demokratische Verantwortung
dafür die Union wäre ihr Geld nicht wert
wenn Sie dieses Thema nicht auch mit
harter Sprache aufgegriffen hätte nicht
nur aber insbesondere deshalb weil die
Grünen selber sich ja immer den Mantel
des moralisch hochstehenden gehangen
haben und glaubten sie kämen aus einer
ganz anderen respektablen Fähre es wäre
im Gegensatz zu den anderen Parteien es
begann ja damit dass man einen
erstaunten Blick auf das Organigramm des
Ministeriums hatte und sagte oder über
die Vereinbarkeit von Familie beruft ja
das haben die jetzt aber toll gemacht
das war ja das erste da war die Union
erst noch zurückhaltend dann kam der
Fall dner Trauzeuge da muss ich selber
sagen Leute ich war 23 Jahre im
Bundestag davon 7 Jahre Opposition 16
Jahre in Mitglied einer
Regierungsfraktion was haben wir uns
denn da alles anhören müssen ja glauben
Sie denn wirklich die Grünen hätten in
einer kritischen Zeit der Union gesagt
oh jetzt wollen wir uns aber mal als
bessere sachpolitische Alternative
darstellen und wollen wieder mal in Ruhe
lassen aber erstmal Fusion hat man sie
glaube ich noch nie tätowiert aber das
ist oder das ist das was ich meine die
Wortwahl Kritik also machen sich mal um
die Opposition keine Sorgen wenn Sie
sich einmal ansehen was ich dort in den
letzten Monaten gestapelt hat natürlich
insofern haben sie sogar recht auch an
sachpolitischer Kritik dann kam der Fall
den wir jetzt gerade hatten Trauzeuge
Ferien nur noch obendrauf glauben Sie
mir wäre es bei der Union gewesen hätten
die anderen Parteien in gleicher Weise
reagiert auch von der Sprache her da bin
ich mir absolut sicher ganz schlimm wäre
es wenn man jetzt wirklich die Haltung
einnimmt ohne ein reichen geht ja gar
nichts mehr ich habe das für komplette
Unsinn
Verabschiedungen gewesen wo gesagt wurde
wir wissen jetzt gar nicht wie es ohne
sie oder ohne ihn weitergehen soll es
wird immer weitergehen stell dir vor
dass man entwürdigt ja hunderte von
Mitarbeiter im Ministerium wenn man den
unausgesprochen sagt also auf euch zählt
nicht es kommt nur auf den
Staatssekretär an ich wette es wird Herr
Müller der Chef der Bundesnetzagentur
meiner Meinung nach sogar guter Mann
wenn das der Herr Müller wird wird man
in einem halben Jahr fragen wie es
eigentlich noch mal der Vorgänger von
Herr Müller glauben Sie mir es geht
immer weiter
Demokratie ist jeder ersetzbar das ist
wohl so ich glaube das was klar wird ist
ja das Patrick reichen ja schon seit
Wochen in der Kritik stand und zwar
massiv wegen dieses Gesetzes was er
maßgeblich ausgearbeitet hat
dem heizungsgesetz heizungsverbotsgesetz
ab 2024 wie auch immer man es nennen
will und dann kommen gewisse Dinge noch
oben drauf und ähm Patrick reichen hat
zusammen mit Robert habe dafür gesorgt
dass die Grünen in ganz ganz schweres
Fahrwasser gekommen sind und sich darin
befinden und einfach nicht das gewohnt
sind diese Erfolgswelle die sie oder auf
dieser Erfolg der schwimmen diese bisher
gewohnt sind und wer Bundeskanzler
werden will und dass wir Robert habe ja
immer noch werden der hat natürlich ein
Problem auch dann damit wenn ihm der
Wind richtig von vorne ins Gesicht bläst
und er eine
Kommunikationsstrategie fährt wie er sie
gefahren hat und ein Gesetz vorliegt das
wirklich Millionen von Deutschen quasi
die Faust ins Gesicht schlägt das ist
einfach so es ist unausgegoren gewesen
völlig unüberlegt liegt auch daran bei
Robert habe sich lediglich mit Öko
Spezialisten umgibt aber nicht mit
Ökonom oder auch mit Menschen die
vielleicht wissen wie das Leben auf dem
Lande ist und wie es sich anfühlt ein
Haus zu haben 65 Jahre alt zu sein aber
gar kein Geld gar keine gar keine
Rücklagen zu haben um möglicherweise
noch Dinge zu sanieren das ist aus
Berlin gedacht für eigentlich nur Berlin
aber nicht für den Rest des Landes und
das steht jetzt zurück ich finde
allerdings den Vorwurf an Patrick
reichen oder Robert habe dass das Gesetz
was sie da jetzt vorgeschlagen haben
dass das so nicht machbar ist weil uns
sozial Patrick reichen ist einfach
Mensch ne die Sozialkompetenz von
Patrick reichen mag ich nicht
einschätzen aber dass dein Mann der
kommt vom Fach und es ist jetzt nicht
genau die Aufgabe vom Bundestag von der
Opposition dass sie dieses Gesetz
anschaut und tatsächlich konstruktive
Vorschläge gemacht wie man das sozial
verträglich und sozial auch machbar
umsetzen
muss ihnen doch aufgefallen sein dass
die FDP mittwochs im Kabinett zugestimmt
hat und wenige Tage später auf dem
Bundesparteitag beschlossen hat dass das
so nie gesetzt werden darf das ist doch
nicht die Opposition ja ist die FDP ist
ja so ein Hybridwesen zwischen Regierung
und Opposition also was die FDP da
abzieht finde ich auch nicht wirklich
trägt nicht zur Stärkung dieser
ampelregierung bei und ich kann es noch
mal sagen ich finde was die Union dort
abzieht das ist wirklich das ist ein ein
Destruktion an destruktivismus
einfach ab sie lenken ab und sie machen
etwas was bekannt ist für die Grünen
oder ich bin auch immer aber warum
lenken sie eigentlich von von von 20
Jahren
warum warum kritisieren sie eigentlich
diejenigen die was kritisieren lassen
Sie uns doch mit den Dingen
auseinandersetzen es gibt 88 Verbände
die sich zu dem heizungsgesetz geäußert
haben darunter sind so namhafte Verbände
wie der Bundesverband der deutschen
Industrie und die beispielsweise gesagt
haben Patrick reichen hat sukzessive die
Kosten die auf die Bürger zu kommen
massiv zu niedrig angesetzt ja und wenn
wir eine Regierung haben bei der sie
dann sagen ja ein Bundestag wird ja
sowieso alles besser gemacht dann fragt
man sich auch warum haben wir die
Regierung dann eigentlich in diesem in
diesem Ausmaß warum brauchen wir so
viele Staatssekretäre wenn das was da
rauskommt dann ja eh morgens ist und
noch mal verbessern werden soll dann
brauchen wir die ganzen Staatssekretäre
nicht dann macht sie bei der Bundestag
gleich also ich glaube das ist auch so
eine fadenscheinige Argumentation eine
Regierung etwas beschließt dann muss sie
hinter dem Gesetz stehen mit Haut und
Haaren ich glaube auch Robert habe das
in der Tat andere aus der FDP tun das
nicht trotzdem hat man das Gesetz
verabschiedet aber die Kritik ist so
massiv von den verschiedensten Verbänden
selbst von wärmepumpenverband aus
anderen Gründen dass man doch nicht
sagen kann das wäre eine Kampagne der
Union naja aber also gehen wir doch auf
die Kritik keine inhaltliche Kritik die
Union startet eine Kampagne mit dem
Namen verheizen und dann werden
tragische Schicksale von Menschen dieser
tatsächlich gibt vorgezeigt wo es heißt
ihr verheizt mein Lebenswerk oder so das
ist doch kein konstruktiver Beitrag für
ein Problem was wir doch alle angehen
müssen genau das Problem ist das Problem
ist ganz ja hier wird hier soll das ist
sicherlich auch richtig dafür gesorgt
werden dass aus dem Gebäudebereich
weniger CO2 ausgestoßen nur die ist die
Frage wie macht man das ja man kann
hingehen und sagen ab sofort dürft ihr
nicht mehr mit Öl und Gasheizungen
heizen könnte man machen wer Vorschlag
eins so nicht geplant in der Tat aber
das was da geplant ist kommt dem relativ
nahe mit dem Verbot ab 2024 keine neuen
Öl und Gasheizung mehr einbauen zu
können
ist doch interessant dass die soziale
Härte dieses Gesetzes kritisiert wird
aber dann habe ich mir den das
Positionspapier der CDU durchgelesen was
sie denn alternativ vorschlägt und da
steht ein Satz nur drin dass die der der
einsatzförderung soll bei 50 %
ungefähr soll die betragen im Gesetz
steht tatsächlich bis zu 70%
gemacht das ist hier nicht erlaubt aber
sie kriegen heute noch Redezeit ja das
verstehe ich wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
ihren
falls kämpft für Sie